imagine it's friday night you grab a
drink
hop into voice and you're ready to sit
down with your favorite game
only when you start it up nothing
happens
if you're one of our indian viewers you
might not have to imagine this problem
you might be living it and that's
because in september
the indian government banned the
country's most
popular game and what's happened since
is honestly just insane
[Music]
okay guys so we've been reporting all
sorts of stories on the channel recently
why don't you hit that sub button ring
the notification bell
and let us know if there are any stories
you're keeping an eye on
if you see something that you think
might be a great fit for the channel you
could let us know
at our tips email tips at thescore.com
so on september 9th the indian
government issued a ban on over
100 apps most of which had some
connection to chinese companies
one of those apps was incredibly
important to competitive gaming in the
country
dank tanks
nah i'm kidding there was an app called
dank tanks and
it was banned but it's not the important
one i just wanted to say dank tanks in a
video
i'm talking about the biggest game in
india pubg mobile
the ban came after some tensions between
china and india
over a section of their shared border
the move has also been linked
to prime minister narendra modi's
self-sufficient
india slogan the government technically
didn't
specifically call out chinese developers
but it did say that the banned app's
developers were
quote engaged in activities which are
prejudicial to sovereignty
and integrity of india defense of india
security of state and public order if
this sounds familiar
recall that tiktok is actually facing a
similar ban in the u.s
pending both a court challenge and a
potential acquisition
okay so that's why the app was banned
but
why is pubg mobile the most popular game
in india
well mobile esports has become the
fastest growing section of competitive
gaming there
and it's for practical reasons mobile
data in india is some of the cheapest on
the planet
yeah way cheaper than north america or
europe and while
pcs and gaming consoles exist they're
rarer than the most popular gaming
platform
the smartphone pubg mobile was the
region's
hottest esport overshadowing all sorts
of other titles
tsm even partnered with a local org to
back a pub g mobile team
the game was absolutely massive in terms
of player count it was the single
largest market for the game
and it boasted over 33 million daily
active users
in india alone when the app was banned
it apparently dropped 10 cents valuation
by 34 billion dollars
that's right billion and this number is
based on a projected
future loss of revenue not the current
income that the company makes from
indian players
which is admittedly smaller than some
other regions
so if the indian government was trying
to hurt or reprimand
china in some way it looks like they
succeeded
anyways pubg mobile gets banned in india
casual fans can't play it pros can't
compete
and content creators most of whom are on
youtube because twitch doesn't have any
indian servers
have to find something else to play for
the majority of people youtube just
makes a lot of sense
and youtube streaming is just exploded
in india like
we didn't have any good streamers and
then suddenly pubg mobile comes about
and now you have like
at least like five streamers who have
like over a million subscribers
some of these people went to other
mobile games like garina free fire
a sort of colorful third person battle
royale
or to call of duty mobile among us also
saw a boost from this
but others branched out from their usual
platform
and new games became winners as a result
one example is valorant which has seen
an increase in viewership even though
the country is still very mobile-centric
with them being banned they're actually
switching to valerent and all these big
streamers are actually playing valorent
and that's forcing more people to
actually watch it people who weren't
necessarily interested in pc gaming to
begin with
uh that's actually created a huge
viewership for valor and in india at
least
maybe pubg mobile being banned isn't
enough to create a massive country-wide
shift to valorant
or even to popularize pc gaming more
generally
but it could definitely help in terms of
esports scene ballarant is like
booming there are a lot of people
watching it
for indian numbers and i think it will
continue to grow for a while as long as
the streamers itself
who hold this gaming community glue
together keep streaming their game and
keep playing that game
but remember that tsm entity team i
mentioned earlier
it's not been officially confirmed but
there have been videos that hinted that
the roster might actually be learning to
play an entirely new game
in the absence of pubg mobile i'm
talking about
league of legends wild rift a game that
aims to replicate the big league of
legends experience in a smaller package
but beyond both being played on phones
there doesn't seem to be a lot in common
between both the game's beta isn't
officially available in
india yet but let's just say that vpns
exist and if that switch from shooter to
moba
happens that's wild imagine your
favorite cs or cod team
forced to make a hard transition to
league of legends
i mean i want to see simple play draven
yes
anyways so pub g corp has been without
their huge
indian player base for a while but they
haven't been idle
about a week after the ban they
announced that tencent would no longer
be responsible for publishing pubg
mobile in india
but there hasn't really been a response
from the government yet more recently
someone spotted a job posting for a
position with pubg corp
for a corporate development division
manager based
in india that led to speculation that
pubg mobile might soon be unbanned
but as an article on fosbytes pointed
out the posting doesn't specifically
mention the mobile game
so there's no way to know exactly what
the posting is for
without you know applying obviously this
isn't proof of
anything besides the fact that pubg corp
is looking to hire some people
but it's worth keeping an eye on but in
any case we'll be watching this one
closely
this is honestly a ridiculous story that
hasn't gotten a lot of attention
outside india itself and as even the u.s
considers
similar bans aimed at china it's a
situation we could see play out
in countries across the world although
for the sake of the games we all spend
our time on
i really hope not this is what i'm
talking about
he just jumps up look he's literally on
the back of my trees just perched
this is like this is the best part of
his whole day well besides food
he loves food but yeah this is
this is my cat no this cat look
look look at this cat
he's just loving life right now this is
what he does this is his whole thing